[Musique]
n'avez vous jamais voulu savoir
ce qu'il y a au delà des murs de la zone
de quarantaine
ceci est un message de la sécurité
intérieure pour prévenir toute nouvelle
contamination d accès à la cité ont été
condamnés oui
mystère
patxi
là
[Musique]
ils patrouillent avec des masques mais
qui sont ils réels mon père pourrait
être l'un d'entre eux
[Musique]
tu dois savoir qu'il n'ya jamais eu
d'épidémie
ni de contamination les autorités font
régner la peur pour contrôler les
populations et faire disparaître ce qui
possède un ton il ce dont il sommeille
en toi mais je ne compte pas rester ici
je vais le retrouver
venez avec moi
abigail
me voici
[Musique]